a big debut for a tiny car the world
premiere of the new smart at berlin's
tempodrome events center drew over 700
journalists from around the world and
once the nifty coupe drove onto the
stage there was no holding back everyone
wanted a piece of the action
the new smart is being rolled out in two
chassis versions the two-seater four-two
and the four-seat for four the four-four
once bore little resemblance to its
two-seat cousin but that has now changed
smart chief designer kai zieber says
most people would have trouble
differentiating between the two cards
from the front and back it's only from
the side it's obvious it's an extended
for two but sieber says it was important
to hold on to iconic features so that
people recognize it as a real smart
right away even though the proportions
might vary
the new generation smart fortwo part of
germany's daimler has an all-new design
most notable in the front the engineers
managed to retain the overall length of
its predecessor at 2.69 meters but the
new version is 10 centimeters wider that
means a roomier interior and more leg
space and its tight turning circle under
seven meters is hard to beat
for those wanting to take more
passengers the smart for four is the
better option with a length of 3.49
meters there's room for four people and
once the seats are folded up total
luggage capacity is 975 liters and in
contrast to its predecessor the engine
is located beneath the rear trunk for
daimler it was high time to bring a
larger smart model to market
smart ceo annette winkler says the brand
has lots of fans but many people say
they can't buy a smart because they have
children or want to take luggage so now
the company can offer a bigger car
both models have new features the smart
comes with a five-speed manual or dual
clutch automatic transmission and the
new version has a three-cylinder engine
that puts out 52 kilowatts average
consumption is 4.1 liters for 100
kilometers the new smart developed
together with daimler partner renault's
twingo has struck a cord with car
experts
i think he's more comfortable
i like also the situation of about the
manual
for the manual
he says the new models have cleverly
retained their smart dna but from the
rear the car has a powerful look with a
wide stance
french journalist antoine de la chapelle
is also taken by the new smart he says
for driving in and around big cities
it's a great compact car
you know i think it's a bit more grown
up than the last one it's got a bit more
character at the face of it and um
it's got bigger wheels at the front so
it could be a little bit more sporty and
that's quite interesting in my country
china shanghai
people i mean the married people mom
just love smart for them to pick up the
kids from a school or to go to the
market but sometimes they do have the
another one more person so in that case
there were some awkward
but now the problem just got resolved
it's perfect and i expecting that they
come to china as early as possible
lots of praise at the debut
expectations are running high for the
latest smart cars
what should a top of the line sedan
sound like
like this maybe
cartester matis kourat explains that the
two rows of traffic cones are exactly
four meters 97 centimeters apart and
hardly any of the top of the range
models would fit between them a seven
series bmw is five meters seven and audi
a8 is over five meters thirteen and an
s-class mercedes-benz is about the same
511.
the only car that fits in this space is
the porsche panamera here in the
turbocharged version
this luxury porsche sedan comes with a
turbocharged v8 that emits a brazenly
powerful roar and it's not just noise
its forward thrust is enough to give the
nearly two ton car a sports cars get up
and go
when matus kurat takes the panamera
around a curve he experiences the
agility he's used to from smaller and
supposedly much more nimble cars the
porsche 911s for instance
what happens when porsche's signature
design is applied to a top-line sedan
may not be everyone's groove but it's a
welcome break from the competition's
routine notchbacks and if the panamera
is too short for some car buyers they
can opt for the executive version with
15 extra centimeters the panamera offers
various sports car details and a
surprisingly practical trunk
points out that the body's shape makes
for a trunk that's quite different from
what we'd find in other top-line sedans
for one the rear windshield reaches down
over it so people can see all the
valuables inside a thief intent on
breaking in for example another point is
that the lid is hinged at the roof so if
you open it in a low garage it might
scrape against the ceiling and get the
paint scratched
but it has its advantages as well if
room is needed for a bit more baggage
this roll-up sun blind can be put up to
make way for the bulkier items a normal
trunk wouldn't allow that also the big
lid makes the trunk easier to load
the panamera turbocharged version comes
with pdk dual clutch transmission and
all-wheel drive at a price tag pushing
146 000 euros in germany plus a fuel
consumption rate of at least 10.2 liters
of premium per 100 kilometers but the
turbo easily leaves the factory specs in
the dust launch control takes it to 100
kilometers per hour in less than four
seconds automatically extending the rear
spoiler when it does the 382 kilowatts
of power and 700 newton meters of torque
can make some demands on the driver
it's not just the figures for power and
torque but the feeling that impresses
matas kurat it's comfortable but
muscular with the car starting out slow
and then taking off with a burst of
speed switching to sport or sport plus
mode makes him feel like he's driving a
true race car
engineers outdid themselves with the
v8's repertoire of sounds
says unlike every other top range sedan
the panamera has buttons on the
dashboard that can change the sound and
of course the volume coming from the
exhaust this is how it sounds when the
driver accelerates normally
it starts getting warm and his sound
level meter shows 94 decibels
now he presses this button and steps on
the gas again
it doesn't seem to get any warmer but
the meter goes up to 108 decibels that's
close to the maximum allowable for a car
that's the sound outside what about
inside
tries it out first without pushing the
button
it's only 74 decibels now he pushes the
button
and it edges up to 84 just slightly
louder but more noticeable is the change
in the sound's quality
the interior is easy on both the ears
and the eyes the familiar porsche design
gives form to the steering wheel
instruments and ascending full-length
center console which has just a hint of
an airliner cockpit
in contrast to its competitors the
panamera has split folding rear seats
that leaves room for more luxury
features on the console
so
fast sums up by pointing out that the
panamera has a few things other cars
don't and it offers lots of driving fun
and good workmanship if there's anything
he'd criticize then at most the trim on
the b-pillar it could have been more
solid he personally would not need a
turbocharged engine given the extra
price and higher fuel consumption he
noted an average rate of 15 to 16 liters
per hundred kilometers on his test drive
but that's a ballpark figure better fuel
consumption comes with the diesel or
diesel s engines
or diesel s
it costs over 80 000 euros to take a
panamera of one's own on the road in
germany even the entry-level model
combines sporty handling with abundant
luxury but the turbo's unmistakable
sound will always hold a certain
fascination for porsche fans and drown
out factors like price fuel consumption
and green qualities
volkswagen shiroko has been treated to a
facelift bringing it closer to the gulf
both visually and technically in
addition to a redesigned front
reminiscent of the golf gti it's been
given the gti's 2-liter direct injection
turbocharged engine which pumps out 135
kilowatts the interiors pay homage to
the original shiroko with additional
instruments
bmw has broken new ground with its
2-series active tourer its first compact
mpv with front-wheel drive equally
unusual is the three-cylinder 100
kilowatt engine the seats are now 12
centimeters higher and the back seats
can be pushed forward 12 centimeters too
allowing additional luggage space in the
468 liter rear the active tourer starts
at 27 200 euros in germany
the astra is one of opel's most
important models whether as a three-door
gtc sports coupe or as a sports tour
station wagon now the company in
russeltheim germany has unveiled a new
range of engines for both the astra
family and for its other cars
jurgen keller says the gm subsidiary has
a new 1.6 liter gasoline engine and a
1.6 liter diesel and it's calling this
the whisper diesel it's extremely quiet
but has great performance and it offers
power even at lower rpms
we're testing this whisper diesel in the
beefier 100 kilowatt version found in
the astra sports tour automotive
journalist jens meinert is going to put
the new power plant through its paces
while listening closely
the new diesel is especially frugal opel
says it's the most fuel-efficient engine
in its range using 3.9 liters per 100
kilometers and in the smaller 81
kilowatt version it's even 3.7
jens says the engine really is very
quiet it's not only agile and relatively
sporty but also unusually smooth for a
diesel it's a very pleasant engine
one great detail is a sport button that
gives the astra more pep it changes its
steering and performance profile but
also switches the instrumentation to red
from cool white
vexit
both the practical sports tourer and the
sporty astra gtc feature this trick with
the display
now jens turns his attention to the 1.6
liter turbocharged gasoline engine
the gtc is designed for high performance
and that becomes clear in its handling
the gtc's technical data drive the point
home
the turbo engine's 1.6 liters generate
147 kilowatts accelerating it from zero
to 100 kilometers per hour in 7.9
seconds at 6.6 liters per hundred
kilometers fuel consumption is moderate
but only if it's driven gently
the motor
is the engine has been completely
redesigned with multiple markets in mind
gm plans to sell it in the us later it's
a great engine with almost effortless
power there's hardly a trace of turbo
lag in many turbocharged engine the
power kicks in only after a delay and
that's a big plus the engine also has a
beautiful sound it's relatively muted
but gets nice and throaty when you
really fire it up
so whether you choose the practical tour
with its easily folded down rear seats
or opt for the sporty gtc you can treat
yourself to one of the new engines we
tested
it's a common sight a truck traveling
along the highway
but the drivers not steering like in a
science fiction film
at daimler the future of trucking has
already begun this demonstration as part
of a technology event on an unopened
motorway section near monteborg has
caused a sensation in freight haulage
wolfgang bernhard head of daimler trucks
says the mercedes-benz future truck 2025
represents the company's vision for
transport and long distance services a
decade from now
for years daimler has been one of the
leading companies in active and passive
driving assistance systems for both cars
and trucks with safety systems including
proximity control assist stop and go
assist active brake assist 3 and lane
keeping assist these trucks already
offer a high level of safety but what is
now being demonstrated goes even further
says this is a world premiere a truck
that can drive autonomously that means
it can drive all by itself at 80
kilometers per hour without the driver
having to steer it can accelerate or
break stays right in the lane and is
very very safe
autonomous driving is made possible by
networking and augmenting existing
technology with cameras and radar
sensors when the message appears on the
display the driver can activate the
system and turn his seat 45 degrees away
from the steering wheel thanks to the
so-called highway pilot the truck can
now travel without driver input
this system can adjust to a wide variety
of driving situations for example if an
emergency vehicle approaches it can
automatically pull over to the right to
allow it to pass and then return to the
lane without driver intervention the
driver can still take over at any time
but how do truckers feel about that
hans luft is a truck driver
he says the new system is good and less
stressful once you get used to it
it takes some time to get used to
letting go of the steering wheel and
taking your eye off the road
by letting the truck take care of the
driving he says he has time to take care
of other activities in the
cabin foreign
cameras and radar sensors around the
vehicle enable drivers to pay attention
to other things but there's no word from
daimler as to what this technology will
cost autonomous driving is ready for use
in everyday trucking operations freight
haulers that watch the road promise to
make long distance transport safer
this extreme athlete and record breaker
is felix baumgartner of austria he began
his career in the mid-1990s as a base
jumper completing over 2600 jumps so far
you may remember him from 2012 when he
jumped from the edge of the stratosphere
now he's got a new challenge the 24
hours nurburgring race
the austrian former rally driver sepp
hider is leading the audi race
experience team he's only got a few
weeks to turn felix into a real racing
car driver as one of four drivers it's
key that he contribute to the team's
success
the team's leader says their goal is
clear he wants them to get into the top
ten he says they prepared felix well and
felix has also done as much as he can to
get himself in shape they have to do
what they can to minimize any mistakes
swiss racer rahel fry drives felix
around the grand prix track at the
nurburgring to find the ideal racing
line and the entry and breaking points
he's got to know the track like the back
of his hand
fry
goals are always extreme and he wants to
do it as fast as possible
that may be a good quality but for a
24-hour race you need patience she
points out that he breaks too late after
the cusp in the race you only have a
moment to get it right but she thinks
this is really a good start
on the track felix drives kilometer
after kilometer lap after lap always
pushing the car closer to its limits
he's got to make the 419 kilowatt audi
r8 lms ultra as tame and as safe as a
kitten now he's ready
this is not only felix's first try but
also the high point of his ambitious
from heaven to green hell project it
seems his dream has come true competing
on the north loop of the nurburgring
known as green hell and often considered
the world's most spectacular racing
track felix baumgardner and teammates
pierre koffer marco werner and frank
biela are competing against 30 other
teams in the gt3 class they're all going
for overall victory setting out after
the leader a mclaren
eight top makes line up at the start
including bmw mercedes and porsche and
audi is sending eight r8 lms ultras onto
the track at 4 pm the 165 competitors
start the 24 hour race on the 25
kilometer north loop stretch kevin estra
in the orange mclaren had the best start
but a bit further back the battle for
positions begins felix is the fourth
driver in the audi team which is
currently in eighth place he seems a
little surprised at how fast the
professional racers start their day
felix says you see the drivers are
prepared to take bigger risks in a
24-hour race and they go at it a bit
harder he adds it's obvious from the
beginning they give it their all
at 8 17 p.m the race has been going on
for over four hours and felix
baumgardner has to buckle in
he says they're only in ninth place and
he hopes the team won't lose too many
places because of him he admits he just
doesn't have the pacing and performance
skills of the best drivers but thinks he
can hold his own
felix's lap time is around 9 minutes
which is very respectable for a rookie
the top drivers are just about 30
seconds faster he doesn't take any
unnecessary risks and hands over the
unscathed car
felix baumgartner says he managed to get
through but it was pretty difficult
there are often three or four slower
cars ahead of you and each one swerves
in a different direction so the driver
has to maneuver around them what also
made things difficult was the low-lying
sun
felix is recovering from his first
performance and tries to get some sleep
but just after sunrise he's ready again
his second performance in the 24 hour
race is lined up
at six in the morning felix gets into
the car race for the second time at the
moment his team is in overall eighth
place his second performance is better
he seems more at ease with the
conditions and for the first time he
completes a lap in under 9 minutes at 8
minutes 59.7 seconds on the stopwatch
his best lap time on the north loop so
far
felix says he feels comfortable on
nearly every part of the track his
favorite is the north luke he even
prefers it to the grand prix stretch
felix's parents are there for his third
and last race keeping their fingers
crossed thanks to some good performances
from marco werner frank biele and pierre
cuffer and the newcomer felix
baumgartner the team managed to get into
the top ten
felix says everyone's more than happy
ninth place it couldn't get any better
in the first year
audi also secures an overall win at the
24-hour race 2014 with the r8 lms ultra
from team phoenix
and for felix one thing is clear
they'll definitely be back
you